I mean I literally would cry yeah it's
the goodness Lera
no you were 23 also being a fat asian
guy yeah Korean dude doing this in the
late mid-1995 you know all these alley
Wong's and all these other like Jimmy
things and all you should be thanking
you
they should be blowing me but um and
walking the doors true die not to judo
Mizzou the Jackie Robinson of Asia
did I not one of greats right Robinson
one of the great one of the greats am I
not yep you got a dude you know please
shirt down man
he's very talented by the way super
talented a big fan I like I like I've
always liked that guy he's a great
really nice yeah
so they go I go what do they want me to
do they want you to dress up as kim
jeong-hoon and sit in the audience and
do what and they're like we're gonna
really bring a special effects team and
you were gonna make you look just like
him I go cool but what do I do
DL will point you out in the audience
and then we wrote this deal where you
guys used to drift back and forth right
and so I show up at rehearsal he's not
there right so I go but he's not here
and they go we know he will be he knows
yeah he did it with everyone else and
I've been here the whole time he didn't
do with me because yeah he had to do
something he's fine so I spent like six
hours and prosthetic makeup right my
manager is a I don't know how but you
got a seat directly behind me why is it
the best and this is a before this
should they come listen it works best if
you do you stay in character from
beginning to end
I go okay they go even if people talk to
you you just say you're conjunct on all
right so I'm sitting there on full
makeup already so depressing also I
could feel I could feel the sweat
building up inside the cheek prosthetics
so uncomfortable right so it's building
else right every time we're doing here
I'm just saying
you guys know they glue it on there they
glue it I'll do a surgical glue all
right and then put this plastic on your
face it's it's the worst that's not
really breathable yeah and they don't
know you so you're the first one they'd
be added on and either the last when
they take it off right so I'm sitting
there and then deal you I know exactly
what he does for us to get into this
thing and he's going into the thing and
I'm sitting there like this going okay
okay and he doesn't do it as he keeps
talking he's not doing it and I'm
sitting like this and then he goes to a
commercial break right I'm serious I
love wait but like this and I go I'm
going oh thank you for God right and
then all of a sudden like [ __ ]
manager who I'm still with [ __ ] her
she's like this she's whispering that if
they had a camera me from before and
after I wish they had that because
before it was like this but then it was
like three hours you see like just
looking at people right and then my god
it's in Vegas juice I'm not even in LA
right I remember like getting the [ __ ]
off and like the producers going with we
don't know what happened you know I mean
there's nothing there's nothing like I'm
not on in like no you didn't even have a
camera on you really I mean there's so
many of those like show business to see
like nightmarish things that happen in
your career
but you you don't quite know how we're
talking about mark Normand doing that
press in the morning in pour is it
Portland area where you've seen bobbies
no yes
you kiss the girl well grab the remote
press okay we can I stop missed it I
know we were about to say yeah you
already said it
yeah
yeah language-wise I don't listen so
thank you for laughing I'm sorry but
what we say okay let's get back now cuz
you on TV you behave what do you mean
she'd get sport though she's bored whoo
oh yeah yeah yeah so what you're saying
is those those morning ones just cute I
eat so early in the morning yeah I never
know what to do in those morning ones
who does so I'll just chase them around
even dude like I'll kiss them like on
their face yeah like a newscaster like
he'll be talking well you know we've got
a comedian I'll just immediately kiss
him on the cheek
that's them and then like my agent or
some old Kong and go yeah I mean you
can't do that no more that's not the
nineties you can't like touch people
that's so silly
yeah I go it's silly dude loved your
camión The Joker then I had good friends
going I thought I heard your voice bro
you were blurry in the background but I
heard your voice I was like that's bets
a little better yeah movies killing it
though I am killing it here look really
really good yeah man no one saw it in
here I'm waiting till next weekend there
were a lot of weird threats go shooting
like that's fair it's fair I'm gonna go
that's definitely I'm gonna try going
this week for your babysitter
oh yeah trying you know this week
definitely want to see it the critics
were mixed but the people it's a holiday
I know there's such themselves like
they're such fools yeah get out of here
yeah I was doing press in Pittsburgh and
I was on the thing is your boy still he
used to open up for you Oh Ben I mean
I'm bill bill Crawford yeah he was great
he's great they're great great gig
station up there great it was fun man
good times together Matt good guy yeah
but they're like the main voice of the
Pittsburgh Steelers at an NFL expert
he's the play-by-play College Steelers
Wow
and they had another guy who is there
but he does like movie reviews you know
Todd failed me my best friends our good
friend these days and Fatah to him Todd
Phillips started together I know Todd
Phillips you know Todd Phillips yeah
this dude comes on the station [ __ ]
on the Joker hey man oh man not this are
you talking about that's what you
talking about what are you doing oh yeah
what are you doing dude so easy my
friends right what do you
it's so easy to be to hate on Todd
Phillips just shouldn't be making dramas
I'll tell you that much it should have
stick to comedy okay but the direct but
everybody disagrees with you sir [ __ ]
Delia sent me justice a picture of his
neck he sent a text message yeah get the
[ __ ] out of here with $1 chain choker
choker
that's his event that daliyah's is thank
you that's his event further would you
do this weekend it got a chain period
the thing could not have been cheap I
drank coffee and I hung out oh yeah I
don't think he's I don't think he's
posted about on bummer
uh nope you know I can see it no you're
not gonna see all right that's how it's
a thick chain there's a chain here no no
no trust me Jim it's thick I think other
people posted it really yeah centi no
and I saw Whitney post about yeah text
my cell says you know hey guys sorry I'm
the Joker you were so bad my father said
to me when I was 14 15 we were late for
something he said we were gonna miss
this boat and he goes he made it and
he'd look at me because I want the 24
second sat down I knew I was in deep
[ __ ] because you were gonna miss the
boat I was just a [ __ ] idiot I [ __ ]
up with scheduling and he goes I did he
goes I mean let me tell you something
how it goes I want you to hear me now
there are no excuses in the real world
there are no excuses
I don't care there are no excuses I
don't care what happened you either got
it or you don't you can either do it or
you can't get it and the world goes next
I never forgot it he scared me with it
he scared me he goes I don't care bed I
didn't get into [ __ ] the college I
wanted to and I wanted to go to the
college cuz my girlfriend was I was in
love with a college
Wesleyan and he go my mother was like
you know it's okay I know it's hard and
my father goes it's not hold on hold on
if you wanna be a Wesleyan student you
have to do what a Wesleyan student does
and you
didn't do that you get to be that and
that's the way it is I love that [ __ ]
bottom line [ __ ] heartbreakingly
heartbreaking but true get it together
crazy woman at an AOC town hall Maria
her no no Hannah just see I'll just wait
for you soon get it I'm crazy woman we
have that she might have been trolling
it this it seems like you just had to be
strolling she just tried to make many
Bravo sent this to me last two questions
come from Lurline grant and Nicole Mac
Zoe may you raise your hands please
climate crisis we only have a few months
left I love that you support the Green
Deal but it's not get it you know get it
we have fossil fuel it's not gonna solve
the problem faster now that you scream
the swedish professor saying that we can
eat that people but that's not fast
enough so i think your next campaign
slogan has to be this we got to start
eating babies we don't have enough time
there's too much co2 all of you you're
you you know you're pollutant too much
co2 we have to start now
you are so great I'm so happy that you
really support a new great deal but eat
the children say the planet eat the
children Russia we still have too many
people too much pollution so we have to
get rid of the babies that's a big
problem just stopping my babies aside
enough we need to eat the babies under
the spaces thank you no thank you thank
you she's very nice Lucy
so thank you no no not the crazy [ __ ]
so I think I'm out of time for people
like this [ __ ] idiot okay let's see
what she's trolling okay hey all right
okay that's like doing we're really
drunk people after a show my favorite
it's just like all right yeah that's
some big crackhead energy that's cracked
at LSU see I choose just crazy she's
just not good some people are so out of
their [ __ ] minds well she is good I
do agree with her though yeah but why
wouldn't I give that to you as it's a
gift